chi-chi gonzalez for the rockies start
number 12.
two wins five losses the era 5.81
ripped left side base hit paul
goldschmidt
of course seeing better and better at
bats from the cardinal first baseman
as nolan aronado comes to the plate it's
a ground ball hit towards short off the
bat of oronato story to second for one
rogers to first for the double play
got some ground balls that's a good
start for chi-chi
one quality start this year johan oviedo
and again he'll try for his first ever
major league victory 4.26
innings pitch per start to up two down
the o2
a swing and a messy strikes out story
oviedo works a one two three first we go
to the second
tyler o'neal the left fielder leads it
off
they're gonna be there ripped out to
left
o'neal rounding first base on his way to
second
that made it all the way to the wall
he'll stand up at second with
a double you're outta here molina runner
at second and
nobody out yadi hammers it out to deep
left
two nothing cardinals a long one
off the bat of yada yada molina
goodness this ball goes a long way 433
feet off the bat of yadier molina for
yachty that was his first career home
run at coors field
johan oviedo worked a one two three
first inning charlie blackmon brendan
rodgers ryan mcmahon in the second
this ball slot to right center field
indeed
up the very top of the road a leadoff
double for charlie number 13 for
blackman
and runner at third and one out that'll
bring up ryan mcmahon
and this will get the job done mack
grounds out the infield
so here's paul goldschmidt he's singled
through the left side
his first time up 2-2 swung on it missed
he wins the battle with goldsmith that's
out number one in the third
first strikeout tonight for chi-chi
so with two down tyler o'neal is up 1-1
pitch it back through the box backhanded
by rogers leads the flip ahead to story
at second base
who steps on the bag in front of carlson
for out number three
the red hot elias diaz against
johann oviedo this ball allowed to deep
left field and it
is off the top of the glove of o'neill
diaz in the second every ball and he's
hit
lately he's an absolute missile that's
it two outs runner at second base
and garrett hampson will back next pitch
grounded to the right side tommy edmond
gobbles that up again and he throws out
hamson and good work for oviedo in the
third inning so yachty starts things off
in the fourth inning he drives it up the
middle he's aboard
with one out paul de young coming up
line shot dobby catch and yachty
is gonna get doubled up trevor story
with a wonderful play
another splendid effort by trevor story
to flag that liner down so with two outs
the rockies have two on
for cj crone there you go
yadi will give it a look playable
yes he makes the catch so much
concentration to be able to make that
play elias diaz leading off
so elias has hit a home run in three
straight games oh boy it's fourth
straight now
that thing is elias
diaz's profile with rockies fans
is growing exponentially this week
so 451 last night 436
tonight gigi gonzalez it's become
his home mo give up some runs early and
then somehow find a way to get deeper
into the game
see if this ball stays up sinking rider
is caught by
hanson that wasn't easy either because
it was
slicing back so to dive you gotta kind
of
slide dive two outs and the saint louis
sixth ouch and o'neill hit by the pitch
all that ran up and in on him adam olson
out to check on him
check in on him starts the swing a
little bit gets the hands moving just
catches it right there on their right
hand taking a big deep breath as he's
standing on first base talking to stubby
clap
bounced high towards third mcmahon's got
it in fairground
plenty of time to throw out molina and
the hit by pitch does no damage
and mundo sosa takes over at second base
dylan carlson is in left field and
tommy edmond goes to right after
tyler o'neill was hit by the pitch the
go-ahead run is at second for cj crone
this ball hit to right field edmond
going back
it's off the very top of the wall but
man scores
krone the second 3-2 colorado
how many times have we seen cj going
right field
with authority it's not just a weak ball
over there with the
40. tying run in third go ahead run at
the plate here is carpenter
the kick in the pitch swung on and
lifted in the air to left field
rymel tapia right there puts it away
cardinals denied in the seventh they
leave a runner at third as chi-chi
gonzalez turns in a
really good outing tonight at coors
field seven strong
innings from chichi gonzalez and now
he'll give way to
jolie and here's the former rocky
nolan arnotto over seven in the series
and a base hit into center first hit in
the series for nolan arnata one for four
time run on go ahead run comes to the
plate
ground ball to third that's a fair ball
and a great
throw by mcmillan hey
third baseman in the house ryan mcmahon
uncorked that throw from
foul ground and ends the top of the
eighth with a gem
rocky's three cardinals two so here we
go
this is uh foreign territory for justin
lawrence trying to get his first career
save he's got yachtyear molino
brown ball up the middle off of lawrence
deflects to mcmahon who recovers and
throws him out
it helped that it was molina but the
ball
caramed off of justin lawrence ryan
mcmahon
spotted it grabbed it and threw him out
tommy edmond at second bader now at
first
all right here we go rondon with two
runners on two outs
here in the top of the ninth and the
cardinals down three two
rondo base hit and the game is tied here
comes tommy edmond
he scores jose rondon has tied
it tied up three three
how about that haven't had a feeling
like this haven't had a moment
in a while no charlie blackmon trying to
end it in regulation blackman swings
hits a high fly ball
right field tommy edmond is there he has
it
tied at three in denver runners in first
and second
two outs coming to the plate is yada
year molina pitch
molina hits it up the middle bay's hit
a run will score and yachty comes
through
again he does it in the 10th
he's driven in three and the cardinals
have delayed
runners at the corners tommy edmond
edmund slices one and that's a base head
into left
scoring nolan orinato and it's a two-run
st louis lead and all this being done
with two outs here in the tent
bases loaded harrison bader
hammers it out to left grand slam
grand slam harrison
bader they're pouring it on
all of it being done with two outs
they were down to their final strike
wow big fly harrison vader
9-3 cardinal cardinals have a 9-3
lead a six-run top half of the 10th
inning and
the last hope is chris owings a one
ground ball arenado across the diamond
and the cardinals win it they were down
to their final strike and they win it in
10.